here's something interesting last week I
told you about Republican governor from
Ohio Mike DeWine who essentially
abandoned Donald Trump when it comes to
dealing with coronavirus Mike DeWine
took coronavirus seriously from quite
early on one of the one of the earlier
governors to really take action and he
has seen his approval skyrocket thanks
to not following the Trump doctrine and
following the sort of sensible governor
doctrine on coronavirus we've now
learned that Republican Congressman
Peter King from New York who I am no big
fan of is going to be ignoring the
Republican Party and voting for a
democratic coronavirus relief package
that's expected to be voted on later
today if it may already have been voted
on by the time you listen to today's
show now I have mixed feelings about
this in the sense that it is once again
it's a Republican who's personally
affected by something and now is
behaving rationally and doing the right
and pathetic thing I wish it didn't take
that to get them to behave appropriately
and what I mean by that is Peter King is
a New York congressman he represents one
of the hardest hit areas by the virus
it's New York's second congressional
district this is the South Shore of Long
Island so it's not the absolute
epicenter of New York City's five
boroughs but it's as close as you can be
it's it's Juneau the New York City metro
area without actually being there and
that's why he's going to vote in favor
of this package Republicans have been
talking more and more about what if we
maybe limit relief to blue states
they've been hesitant to do more relief
and a second stimulus but Peter King
can't get away with that his district
has been absolutely crushed so there are
some who are framing this as hero Peter
King abandons his party and does the
right thing well it's more like Peter
King abandons his party on this one bill
because it would be political suicide
for him personally not to since he
represents one of the hardest-hit
congressional districts in the country
if it were the Boston area or Seattle
that needed this particular type of bill
and not his district my guess is he
would not be voting for it he would
simply stick it out with Republicans
Peter King is normally no friend of the
left or of the Democratic Party
and this is one it's it's a horrible
realization that we have to have what it
takes for some of these people to do
something to do the right thing is to be
personally affected he needs to be
reelected in November so that's why he
has to do this now as far as the bill
goes there are actually some really
interesting things in it this is called
the heroes Act three trillion in total
it stands for the health and economic
recovery omnibus emergency solutions Act
heroes Act it would pay a company's
payroll costs up to $100,000 per
employee who has been laid off or
furloughed if the business can
demonstrate that their revenue has
dropped at least 20 percent um it would
add eight hundred and fifty billion in
assistance to state and local
governments 200 billion in hazard pay
for frontline health care workers and
other non-essential workers it would do
another round of 1200 dollar checks to
most Americans it would raise the
payment per child from five hundred
dollars also to twelve hundred dollars
but it would be capped total at six
thousand dollars per family it would
extend the Supplemental or I guess
they're calling it enhanced unemployment
from the federal government through
January 31st of next year and one of the
most interesting components that's
buried in there which I don't actually
think will pass if the bill does pass is
that it will eliminate the ten thousand
dollar cap on what's called salt state
and local taxes for 2020 and 2021 this
is super interesting because one of the
ways that the Trump Republican tax
reform of 2017 hurt those in states like
mostly blue tip blue states with higher
state income taxes is they limited the
state and local tax deduction to ten
thousand dollars so if you live in a
very high tax state or just a blue state
with a reasonable amount of tax you are
limited in what amount of tax you can
write off on your federal return to ten
thousand dollars total this goes
directly at blue states and it tends to
have no effect in some of these red
states that have no state income tax so
it would repeal that for 2020 and
21 which is very very interesting
although analysts agree it is very
unlikely that that suspension of the
$10,000 salt cap would actually make it
into a final bill that passes Senate and
House Conference but in the meantime we
will see how the House votes Peter King
apparently will be voting with Democrats
and we will follow it we suspected this
was coming the palpable conflict between
what Donald Trump has been saying and
what doctor foul Chi the top infectious
disease doctor in the country has been
saying the conflicts have been obvious
for months and yet they danced around
the differences until now everything
that has happened to dr. Anthony Fauci
has been absolutely embarrassing for
what it says about our country
coronavirus protesters chanting fire
foul Chi at their protests conspiracy
theories about doctor foul Chi including
bogus videos about coronavirus that
target him as a bad actor Senator Rand
Paul attacking him earlier this week
scolding him saying you're not the
be-all end-all and now Donald Trump
seemingly seeing the door open to start
more directly going after doctor foul Qi
has publicly broken with foul Chi and
saying that doctor foul Chi's claims
earlier this week during the Senate
hearing about we know we may not be able
to open schools in the fall Trump is now
calling that unacceptable unacceptable
and what Trump means really is that it's
politically unacceptable and I'll
explain why in a moment let's take a
look at what Donald Trump said actually
because you know it's just to me it's
not an acceptable answer especially when
it comes to schools the only thing that
would be accepted was I said his
professors teachers etc over a certain
age I think they ought to take it easy
for another few weeks five weeks four
weeks who knows whatever it may be but I
think they have to be careful because
this is a disease that attacks age and
it attacks health and if you have a
heart problem if you have diabetes if
you're a certain age
it's certainly much more dangerous but
with the young children I mean and
students it's really just take a look at
the statistics it's pretty amazing
notice that Trump doesn't present any
counterfactual Trump just says foul
cheese answer is unacceptable and that
doesn't mean it is scientifically
unacceptable it doesn't mean that it is
medically unacceptable what Trump means
is it's politically unacceptable because
if there's no school in September it's
probably not good for Trump's reelection
in November if there's no school in
September that signals likely economic
calamity continuing to such a degree
that it's going to hurt Donald Trump in
November Trump also throws in there by
the way you know kids are mostly fine
and not affected by the virus we've
already covered that children number one
can spread the virus hugely even if they
don't get significantly sick they can
bring it to all of their homes from
school then their parents get it then
their parents can't go to work then
their parents can't earn money you you
understand the problem of this and we
are also by the way seeing a kawasaki
like disease in kids with corona virus
that still needs more investigation
there's been several dozen cases so far
we really don't know that much about it
so far now what this conflict means in
terms of doctor foul Chi's future I
don't know one thing that I like in
terms of breaking from Trump is Mitt
Romney
we've been watching Mitt Romney and Mitt
Romney has started regularly ribbing
Trump during the Senate hearing earlier
this week Romney actually asked doctor
foul Chi Donald Trump has been saying
Obama is to blame for the fact that we
don't have a corona virus vaccine right
now that's ridiculous of course and he
offered doctor foul to the opportunity
to answer and of course doctor foul she
confirmed no not having a vaccine right
now has nothing to do with Obama it also
has nothing to do with Trump and I want
to talk about that in a moment on a
separate topic I my impression is that
which regards to vaccines the the were
I'm critical of what we've done on
testing on vaccines we've done a pretty
darn good job moving ahead pretty
aggressively and yet the president said
the other day that President Obama is
responsible for our lack of a vaccine he
add
dr. Falchi is President Obama or by
extension president Trump if they do
something that that made the likelihood
of creating a vaccine less likely are
either President Trump or President
Obama responsible for the fact that we
don't have a vaccine now or in delaying
it as some in some way
no no Senate another not at all
certainly President Obama nor President
Trump are responsible for not having a
vaccine we moved as you said because I
described it in my opening statement
rather rapidly no one is ever gone so
listen I like what MIT Romney is doing
I'm not rehabilitating Mitt Romney's
image I'm not doing any of that stuff
but seriously who can deny that we would
be better off right now in this crisis
with Mitt Romney as president rather
than Donald Trump but to the other point
that I want to make when we talk about
we don't have a vaccine right now and
that's not Obama's fault obviously and
it's also not Trump's fault I want to
make really clear that you need to be
prepared for a new line of
disinformation that's going to start
relatively soon Donald Trump is going to
take credit for vaccine when there is
one Donald Trump is going to take credit
for treatments as we find more effective
treatments and it has nothing to do with
him understand that it has absolutely
nothing to do with him we eventually are
going to find a vaccine and eventually
people are going to get vaccinated and
eventually the pandemic will end in the
same way that on yesterday's show
outlined for you how no matter what the
death toll is Trump will say thanks to
me it wasn't 2.2 million whether it was
going to be 60,000 or a hundred thousand
or a hundred and sixty thousand or
whatever the number is Trump will always
take credit for it when in fact Trump's
responsibility is that it's going to be
worse than it had to be because of his
slow action when it comes to
vaccinations and treatments they have
nothing to do with Trump but he will
eventually take credit for those as well
depending on when we get those things he
will use them to justify his reelection
in November and he has nothing to do
with why we don't have a vaccine right
now and he will have nothing to do with
us eventually having a back vaccine
never mind that the vaccine that ends up
being widespread in use in the
United States may actually be developed
by a different country altogether don't
forget that stuff this is part of the
disinformation propaganda that they are
using which is deflect on any of the
blame
oh listen PPE the problem was Obama and
governors but we solved it by after two
and a half months finding PPE for people
ventilators oh yeah the problem was New
York didn't buy a whole bunch of them
two years ago and this and that the fact
that we were slow with the national
stockpile that doesn't figure in
anywhere and much the same way Trump
will get credit for the death toll not
being as high as it hypothetically could
have been Trump will try to take credit
rather and it's up to us to remember the
death toll is higher than it needed to
be look at South Korea got their first
case within hours of the United States
getting its first case don't let them
Gaslight you remember I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman and I love hearing from you let
me know what you think the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the David Pakman show
depends on your support and the easiest
way is through membership which includes
the world-famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show just for members sign up
today at join pakman.com coupon code
saves you 40% vote soon 18 the david
pakman show at david pakman.com let's
say thank you to a couple of new David
Pakman show members today those great
people are Joanne Rowan Zhong and Lance
door Joanne and Lance thank you so much
for your support this is a program
mostly funded by you if you want to
support the program you can do so in
mere seconds at join pakman.com also a
huge extra special thank you to greg
Doan greg has been a member for almost
five years and as today's longtime
sustaining member of the day greg Doan
thank you so much
grab a membership it's quick it's easy
and it feels good at join pakman.com
alright let's go to the phones and see
what is on people's minds at 6 1 7 8 3 0
47 50 starting today with our caller
from the tu-16 area code caller from 2 1
6 what's your name where you calling
from today hi David I'm Connor I'm
calling from Cleveland hey Connor what's
up so I was listening to a Facebook live
stream from heather cox richard student
a professor at Boston College right she
proposed something oh boy Connor you're
breaking up my friend yuuichi proposed
what you're breaking up she proposed how
did McConnell know that Hillary wasn't
going to win when you blocked the
nomination of Merrick garland right how
did he know that Hillary wasn't going to
win this locker that did he know
something no I don't I mean listen you
it's a gamble right I mean you might
block it or you might not if your guy
gets in then trunk picks the replacement
it's not
I mean is is it is the idea that it
implies some kind of rigged election or
something like that that could be her
daughter
oh okay I mean I haven't heard what she
said but if you I mean so if you say you
if you block this for a year you might
give the pic to a Republican and if not
listen you still delayed it and okay
Hillary gets to pick but you you at
least had a shot at it it doesn't to me
say that something conspiratorial
necessarily happened interesting so the
chances are that Biden would go ahead
and nominate Garland if he gets the
chance I have absolutely no idea I don't
know that merit Garr I mean that was
years ago I've no clue I've there's so
many people that could be chosen from I
don't I've not heard anything about
Biden and Merrick garland all right
Connor thank you very much I appreciate
the call certainly something to think
about
let's go next to our caller from the
five-10 area code who's calling today
from five-10
uh hey hey David this is a rush from
California hey a rush what's up um yeah
so uh I kind of have a two-part question
okay like firstly from from I like
general understanding when it comes to
like economic development in third-world
countries some of the like the main
contributing factors are like for growth
or like things like education the
infusion of foreign capital the transfer
and select soft skills like and foreign
technology with that in mind do you
think that the policy that Paul he's
involving forced technology transfer
like that is the practice in which in
which a domestic government requires
foreign businesses to share their text
class soft skills in exchange for market
access is that is that a desirable thing
for developing countries with a large
market right yeah and if that in this is
the second part now if it is a good
thing do you think that the rise of
multilateral trade create agreements
which gives stronger protections against
FTT through the enforcement of
intellectual property rights and the
ability to bring nations to court
investor state dispute settlement hurt
there are those those the ability of
those countries to engage in FPT
the answer to all of those questions is
it depends and it has to be looked at on
a case-by-case basis and it's that I'm
not to be clear I'm not picking on you
here when I say this arash but that's
the exact type of question where if
you're looking for a yes or no answer
you're essentially thinking about this
the the the wrong way because there is
the answers to those questions would
depend on what types of technologies are
we talking about which countries are we
talking about what are the underlying
industries and employment circumstances
of those company of those countries what
currency is the prevailing reserve
currency in those countries and how does
that relate to the country in which the
businesses they're looking to buy opera
there's no possible way that I could say
yes that's good and no that's not a
concern about the the arbitration it's
it's such a huge issue I don't see any
simple answer to it yeah yeah I guess I
was thinking it from the perspective of
like one of the arguments in favor of
for example tariffs right yeah the
infant in this industry argument right
so like could there be like like
specific sectors for example like a
high-skilled sectors like
telecommunications or like stuff like or
like you know biotechnology and stuff
like that in which you could help
facilitate the development of these
specific industries through the FTP you
know but that's of course of course
that's certainly possible but it's not
guaranteed and that's why this is the
you you just have to deal with really
specific examples you know multilateral
trade deals Trump increasingly is
talking about bilateral trade deals as
opposed to multilateral and a lot of his
followers are just like yeah Trump says
it's good so that must be good it must
be good because Trump the big boy can
negotiate directly or whatever for me
there's no hard and fast rule about
depending on which countries we're
talking about depending on the scope of
a particular trade deal multilateral may
be more logical or it may not be if you
when looking at the supply chains for
example if you are in a country where
your supply chain for the areas that
you're looking to do a trade deal around
are heavily dependent on five
other countries and you want to do a
bilateral trade deal with only one of
those countries that's a recipe ripe for
creating new problems so maybe a
multilateral deal is more appropriate
there in other cases where there is a
more direct competition and it's a more
an issue of specialization between two
countries maybe in that case it's the
bilateral trade deal that you need my
point is everybody claiming to have the
definitive answer on a lot of this stuff
is is not looking at specific examples
typically okay well uh it's good talking
you David yeah nice calling in for the
show
I appreciate the answer all right
appreciate the phone call Arash thank
you hope to hope to speak to you soon
let's see where are we going next
let's go to let's go to the four one six
area code who's calling today from four
one six hello yes thank you yes it oh
that's very nice hi David I'm a longtime
listener first-time caller
I'm coming from Toronto Canada love it
I'm great show Robert Borgias everyday I
just have a quick question about masks
magical like can you give me like a
brief description like what kind of
masks are there what masks should I wear
or shouldn't you know maybe like because
some people say I should wear them at
all time some people say they're useless
right maybe you know something they
don't okay I don't know anything other
than what the health experts say I want
to make that clear so here's my this is
a good opportunity to talk about masks a
couple different things number one when
you talk about masks there's a big
difference between a scarf a fabric mask
a surgical mask and an n95 mask the n95
mask ordinarily is going to provide the
largest amount of protection both in
terms of releasing your fluids out of
nose and mouth and allowing other fluids
in now there are these masks I've seen
around which have a valve on them a lot
of those are one-way valves where
if you breathe er sneeze stuff comes out
but it protects things coming in those
are not the ones as I understand that
people should be wearing right now
because they're not keeping things in so
that that's number one number two
there's this debate over are the
surgical masks and the scarves and the
fabric masks effective or not effective
and to what degree are they effective
what we know is regardless of the type
of mask if you have two people next to
each other if neither is wearing a mask
and one person coughs versus if one
person is wearing a mask versus if both
are wearing a mask regardless of the
type of mask the the risk of
transmission is lower if both people are
wearing the mask now if they're crappy
masks the attenuation is going to be
moderate but it'll still add up if both
people you'll reduce the chance of
transmission so in terms of what kind of
masks listen the most effective is at an
n95 you can get the KN 95 which is it's
a chinese-made
supposedly up to the same standard mask
there's debate over whether individuals
should really be getting an 95 s because
you are potentially taking them away
from a health care worker I without
stepping into the supply piece what I'm
doing is anytime I go indoors somewhere
I'm wearing a mask
um I from what I've seen doctor foul Qi
and others say that outdoor contagion
unless you're crowded at you know a
hiking trail is almost none like the the
vast majority of the contagion is
happening within people's own households
then it's happening at people's
workplaces it's happening in health care
settings but the outdoor contagion you
know some articles floated around about
you know you could jog past someone and
you could cough right as they breathe in
and then they've got the virus there is
essentially no evidence I've seen that
that is going on so when I am just
walking around I am not wearing a mask
at this point in time okay and you said
you wear a mask indoors is it surgical
or is it like
you've made it on your own actually a
viewer who makes them and sells them
sent me a couple and it's it's a fabric
mask
okay I'm just working in a place where
you know I have a few customers coming
by once in a while so I'm you know it's
really hard to get masks in Toronto and
I don't want to take them away from
medical workers if they need them yeah
at this point though it should be pretty
easy to get the the surgical masks not
that 95s you can get my understanding is
from what I've seen I don't know Amazon
Canada but in the u.s. you can get a 50
pack of surgical masks for like 30 bucks
yeah but I remember like a few weeks ago
it was 150 not like five times yeah yeah
yeah
no you're absolutely okay thank you
alright my friend thank you great to
hear from you in Toronto very much
appreciate it let's go next to our
caller from the 6-3 one area code who's
calling today from 631 hi David it's me
yes it is hi um this is spinny chair
from Long Island thanks Vee before you
go on if you can put the phone a little
further from your mouth because you're
absolutely maxing out our system and it
becomes hard to hear just keep the phone
a little further away from your mouth
please try it from here oh I love it the
other day you had a video about social
democracy and populism that I found very
interesting but I thought there was more
to flesh out because you yourself you do
have an anti-establishment criticism you
know you will criticize what you call
the Democratic establishment and I think
that's what extent is populism so I
don't know if you can kind of square
that circle because you do engage in
some populist arguments but you do
manage not to um I guess fall off the
deep end with it yeah I I mean I guess I
don't there's really no conflict between
so the analysis was basically an
analysis of it's harder to pervert and
bamboozle with social democracy than
with populism that was my assertion
essentially and as I said in the video
that doesn't mean left populist ideas
are wrong so the the way that I square
it is I believe in social socially
democratic policy and certainly there
are good left populist ideas and I have
some of those ideas but the analysis was
that it's very easy to pervert populism
and you end up with right populism and
it can even go into authoritarianism
that was the analysis so I maybe I'm not
understanding the question but I don't
know there's anything to square also in
other words you wouldn't say that you
have a somewhat populist analysis but
that you don't go off the edge with it
like maybe a moderate populism you you
you were to say that you're just a
social democrat listen we're getting
into sort of like labeling everything I
I guess my general political views
economic views are of social democracy
there is certainly overlap in terms of
many of the goals with left populism but
the story was not so much about my views
per se but about the ways in which
populist rhetoric has been perverted in
many cases and ends up being something
very different than what's promised okay
well maybe if I could phrase it in a
different way I just lost my train of
thought I'll head out now have a good
day David all right very good appreciate
the phone call great to hear from you
yeah people so we have dramatically
improved our phone system over the last
two weeks where we have a very small
delay as people can probably tell the
only downside is I have less of an
ability when that crunching sound
happens it's it's in the system it's not
on my end so people need to talk a
little quieter and maybe keep the phone
a little further away both very very
important elements of making a good
phone call right now let's go to our
caller from the 7:08 area code caller
from 7:08 what's your name where you
calling from hi david glenn calling from
saint louis how you doing good what's up
Glenn I'm just wondering you say today
you still you think that the United
States is doing the worst on a car virus
situation
wonder if you still think on that even
though a lot of European countries have
higher death rate and I know we're on
per-capita not doing as great testing
volume but we are doing better than
France I believe and when you put that
statement I was kinda confused how you
would actually think do you have to be
worse than China when China was the one
who let it like spread and kind of lied
to the World Health Organization if you
you want to go into how to extended a
lie but kind of seemed like they
probably would have the worst handling
out of any country okay please try to
keep the phone a little further from
your mouth because you are clipping so
you there's a lot of different stuff
there that you mentioned so let's let's
step back for a little bit one thing is
I in my if you're referring to my tweet
I actually said we don't know the truth
about the situation in China so it's
hard to compare our response to China's
response because clearly China has not
been honest about it so I made that
caveat so I don't know would've been the
worse than it there if we know they're
not being true about of them and from
there I don't know what the truth is of
the Chinese response because we just
don't know they're certainly being
dishonest that we can say I don't know
exactly how bad their response has been
in terms of other countries it's
becoming very clear that Russia and
Brazil are doing very very poorly they
seem to have benefitted early from the
fact that it came first to the u.s. but
Russia and Brazil's curves are
disastrous so by the time it's that
what's difficult about this is the the
outbreak started at different times so
we're not necessarily comparing apples
to apples but Brazil and Russia by the
time it's all said and done may
certainly be up there but one of the
things we can start to look at is the
duration of the curve before you start
seeing dramatic decreases in cases and
deaths and certainly when you look at
places like Spain and Italy I mean South
Korea at the very top of the list Taiwan
these are places that sometimes in a
matter of 10 or 14 days reversed the
curve whereas we are now going on you
know multiple months there are states
that are
now having huge growth rates like Texas
and others so I'm not saying the US
response has been the worst it's
certainly been of the worst I still
allow this area that I was still
wondering it seemed like when I saw some
her tweets and showed you say no worse
it's curious about what country we can
definitively say was worse Iran may have
been worse for example China I mean
we're doing we're doing better testing
per capita and better that's raised in
France
okay so we're right now we're fortieth
and testing per capita so we can
certainly find countries and say we're
better on this metric than that country
that we can certainly do but I don't
know what that gets us necessarily I
mean no I'm just saying like I mean what
what metric you said you're just looking
at the metric of rising rates of who's
doing better who's doing of like what's
doing better cuz there's a whole bunch
of different stuff that you would look
at and and Glenn I mean really gonna
need you to keep the phone further from
your mouth because that the sound really
could so we look at a lot of different
things we look at how long after the
first case did testing get up to a
certain level per capita we were
terrible on that we look at death rate
our death rate is the 12th or 13th
highest in the world you look at testing
per capita we're 40th in the world
there's a whole bunch of different stuff
that that we look at there's not just
one metric okay we all right now I I
agree was more than one metric I I I
guess I would say infirmity servile and
I justified from the numbers we I say we
was in the middle but I think it's also
hard to compare country to country
because not every country is basically
the same 7% of countries out of 180
countries were like 12th or 13th that
seems pretty bad to me Glenn I
appreciate the phone call I've got a run
we're gonna take a quick break if you
were holding don't hang up
because I will go right back to the
phone
after this the david pakman show at
david pakman.com the david pakman show
depends on the support of our viewers
and listeners and one way to keep us
going is through patreon where you can
pledge as little as one dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well read about him welcome
back to the David Pakman show
welcome back we are going to go right
back to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
and see what is on people's minds let's
go to our caller from the eight one five
area code who's calling today from eight
one five yes it is all right so I kind
of have a two-part question here you're
no doubt familiar with basically how the
whole right pipeline worked a few years
ago like I've even seen you do videos on
it yep do you think something is you
know something similar is happening in
the opposite direction and I don't mean
like the conservative idea of anything
even remotely progressive socialist that
means do you think there is now
currently a similar pipeline that is
turning people into actual socialist
actual conjugates
well what the thing about calling it a
pipeline I mean so listen there are
people that go into and come out of a
political ideology all the time there
are people that become outright and
people that stop being all right all
right there are people that become
socialists and who stopped being
socialists etc that's normal the
question about calling it a pipeline to
me is more one about is there a
particular path that we can identify
that is either happening through like
proactive propaganda movements or
indoctrination movements
disinformation or simply like algorithms
online I mean I'm open to the idea that
there is something similar going on with
socialism I'm just I'm just not aware of
it I mean certainly there's socialist
voices on websites like YouTube and
Reddit and Twitter and you can certainly
create an echo chamber for yourself of
socialist voices whether there's a
pipeline per se
I don't have enough information to say
like what do you have in mind what do
you identify as that pipeline
well the biggest pieces of evidence of
this in my opinion are the rise of a lot
of popular overtly socialist content
online like there's tons of socialist
youtubers out there with tens if not
hundreds of thousands of subs it's
basically just blowing up online and the
second part of the question would be do
you think this is a good or bad thing
for the last in America well there's two
that they depend so I am NOT a socialist
so if the question is do I think the
democratic party needs to start running
on socialism my personal answer is no
but that's not happening if the question
is are we better off if more people are
exposed to the ideas of socialism and
understand them for what they are rather
than the cartoonist cartoon ax fide
things that the Wright likes to say I'm
all for that yeah okay yeah yeah yeah no
I listen I took Marxian economics at the
University of Massachusetts as an
undergraduate my professors there were
Richard Wolff the socialist economist
and the late Steve Resnick and it was
one of the few schools that was actually
offering as part of their Economics
Department serious classes on on Marxian
economics and I'm better for it it
didn't turn me into a socialist but I
now understand some about those ideas I
think that's great
socialism okay but I think the spreading
of these socialist ideas online is cause
a lot of people on the left to act in
ways that are kind of counterproductive
like for example I'm actually in a few
socialist discord of a few of the bigger
socialist content creators yeah and it's
a very common narrative there that
basically electoral ISM is dead there's
no point in participating in this
election the only way we're going to get
real change in this we take direct
action outside of the system
don't bother voting for Biden and it
won't matter okay so let me let me
address that so here's the thing every
movement is going to create some very
loud people who will turn what you're
describing is acceleration ax Stitz
basically like working within the system
no longer works you need to destroy the
system that's not unique to socialism
right I mean we've the Tea Party
extremists also had a component of
acceleration ax stuff about ways in
which society needs to be broken down
and sort of like rebuilt white
supremacists fundamentally are talking
about you know significantly
acceleration estai Diaz and in many I
don't I think it would be unfair to say
that that's unique to socialism there
are certainly people who start following
socialist theory learning about it and
they end up in the position
that's not most of them and I don't
think that that is the we could say that
that's unique to socialism I don't think
we need to be more worried about
extremist socialists than we need to be
worried about extremist libertarians or
extreme know whatever I think that at
the extremes of most movements you will
find people whose ideas are very
unlikely to ever really be mainstreamed
and to put too much emphasis on them
probably probably doesn't make sense
listen I appreciate the call I I do want
to move on because I've got some other
people that want to get on here but very
important topics for sure let's go to
our caller from the six seven eight area
code
who's calling today from six seven eight
six seven eight hey how are you who's
this hey max what's up on seemingly
republican states red states are opening
up rather fast and it seems like it
seems like the media and just the
general population of the country even
if even if cait's rates are going up and
death rates are going up it doesn't
really seem to hit home with a lot of
people you know if you don't lose the
left one or something like that so as
case even if case rates do keep spiking
and going up and as states continue to
open do you see down the line in the
November election if we have it on time
maybe Trump gaining Brown is gaining
approval with his denial you know of
that there's actually a problem and
maybe red states will be flourishing a
little bit more and if we keep it under
you know who keep hospitals from
capsizing over there limits yeah good
okay very very good question so there's
there's two ways that this could go now
let me make clear I would love it I
would genuinely love it if all of these
red states that open up don't see a
resurgence I would love what do you see
that it doesn't happen and that things
just go great and then blue states can
open up and then everything's lovely and
then we go and hopefully we remove
Donald Trump in November anyway but your
question is a good one which is if the
numbers do keep getting worse in these
red states and it's already happening to
some degree it's happening in Texas it's
happening in Georgia Tennessee is
increasingly a disaster etc I think in
the short term Trump strategy will work
which is normalize it pretend
everything's fine okay I mean yeah some
people are dying but this is the new
normal it's status quo I think it'll
work for four weeks six weeks maybe
eight weeks but when it continues and
then you also get the disastrous second
quarter GDP numbers in August I don't
think it's going to work for Donald
Trump to just keep insisting
everything's fine I I don't I think it's
a short-term play if by chance there are
no resurgence --is
Krum opening i'll be happy because i
don't want there to be but it will work
out for trump to some degree otherwise i
think it eventually will completely
backfire on him yeah do end up keeping
it under you know the limits where you
know they're at least functioning yeah
but yeah alright my friend very great I
appreciate the phone call thank you so
much let me go next to our caller from
the 303 area code who's calling today
from three zero three three zero three I
just heard a pop I think you're there
hmm interesting all right
I think three zero three is gone let's
go instead to our caller from the 972
area code who's calling from 972 I gave
it as Daniel from Texas oh yeah I know
what's going on I have a question for
you so I'm a big advocate as a metaphor
for all like many of your listeners and
yourself one of the questions that come
up from my friends and family and should
it be included in a medicare-for-all
option or whatever plan that we come up
with that we are including all of the
insurance employees as part of
retraining or even bringing them on to a
government Rand system or should it be
included in the budgeting for that or
how would you make sure that a the
Democratic Party since they'll be the
ones that wind up pushing it through how
do you plan that they will do it versus
how do you think it should be done to
incorporate all those people who lose
their jobs well here's the thing a lot
of the people that work in the health
insurance industry don't really need to
be retrained in this they are gonna need
to find new jobs for sure but it's not
really the training piece that they need
help with what I mean by that is so
everyone who's a service provider would
just continue like if your doctor you
stay a doctor if you're a nurse you stay
nurse okay executive level people Human
Resources people you know all of these
people that work at health insurance
companies they're their skills would
still be in demand as is at
companies we would just need to find
other companies for them so certainly
that would be a piece of it there's
really only a slice of health care
company employees that would really need
retraining I mean okay maybe you don't
need nearly as many medical billing
people and that's a really specific
narrow job that would be less relevant
you'll still need some of them because
remember single-payer still involves
billing it's just that there's one payer
so I actually don't know that retraining
is really the thing I think it's going
to be more a jobs program to figure out
where are they going to go do they get
involved in government infrastructure
programs do we transition them over to
green energy stuff like that is a
question I don't know that retraining is
really the issue I agree and I agree
with that I'll just kind of one of the
set the stage there for your thoughts on
it and do you think do you think that
the numbers should be included in any
budgets only have debates or discussions
about that regarding the the cost of
that or do you see it already shown in
those numbers I don't know the answer
it's already in the numbers I simply
don't know yeah and my belief because I
want to be transparent is yeah if we
think about what it's going to cost to
do Medicare for all I want to include in
that whatever costs we are including to
transition a lot of the people that will
lose their jobs over to Nuge I would
include that now Republicans in bad
faith would simply say oh so it costs
even more than you said right I mean
like so but so so for political reasons
maybe it's best not to include it but if
I really want to holistically think
about what's the total cost here I would
include the transition costs for how the
government will support health care
company employees moving elsewhere great
thank you have a good one all right
appreciate the call thank you so much
okay I don't have time to take more
calls today but I will take calls again
and I really appreciate everybody who
called in hope to hear from you very
very soon
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
whether you're looking for david pakman
show coffee for your Chemex or French
press or a David Pakman show t-shirt
it's all available on our website
shipping to anywhere in the world at
david pakman.com slash gear
don't miss the bumper stickers to david
pakman.com forward slash gear the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
all right let's get into audience
questions for the week very relevant and
prescient questions today the first is
hey David could so-called rhinos be
better allies for removing Trump than
the never Biden people in November of
2020 rhinos are Republicans in name only
okay I think that thinking that is sort
of defeatist tanned I'm gonna tell you
why there is no doubt that there is a
Republican movement that hates Trump and
wants to remove him this includes people
like George Conway the husband of Trump
advisor Kellyanne Conway this includes
people like you know the Steve Schmidt
is an advisor and Rick Wilson who I've
interviewed on the show these are
Republican strategist types who don't
like Trump and want to see him removed
now the question about allies could be
interpreted two ways number one is just
like in the sheer numbers of it do I
think there will be more Republicans who
abandoned Trump and vote Biden then the
number of never Biden people who would
normally be Democratic voters but are
going to either not vote or vote third
party or vote for Donald Trump I think
the answer is no I mean listen every
every election there is abandonment if
you look at 2008 there were a bunch of
people who voted for Hillary in the
Democratic primary and then voted for
John McCain in 2016 you saw some Bernie
primary voters who abandoned Hillary
abandoned the party so to speak and
voted for Trump it was actually a
smaller number than the number that did
the abandonment in 2008 and went to
McCain every election you have that I
don't think the numbers actually going
to be that big and I know that the the
never Biden movement is very very loud
online but you have to understand that
there's a lot of things that are very
very loud online and it turns out that
they don't really reflect reality as
closely as we might imagine or we might
even hope the Bernie run is an example
of that so much online activity and then
Bernie lost three consecutive super
Tuesday's only the last of by that I
mean the three Tuesday's in March that
have a bunch of elections only the last
one was
even moderately affected by the
coronavirus and there's no particular
reason to believe that that actually
hurt Bernie more than it hurt Biden so I
don't actually think that the never
Biden movement is going to be what
prevents Biden from winning I think that
there is no question though that we
should welcome Republicans who are not
going to vote Trump once Trump's out
whoever the next president is either
Biden in in winning in November or some
other Democrat winning four years from
now at some point those Republicans are
going to be back to disagreeing with us
on most policy and that's it so the idea
of them being allies anybody who doesn't
vote for Trump votes for Biden right any
one of those votes helps remove Donald
Trump and we'll take it and we love it
and it's all fantastic the more people
that realize that this guy is a lethal
Menace the better and more efficiently
that we can remove him but I worry about
the hostility of saying man some of
these Republicans are better allies than
the never Biden people we it's not one
or the other we need everybody and there
are reasons why people might be
Republicans and not want Trump that
would be completely unaligned with our
values he might be not really a small
government conservative they hate that
he did the stimulus like there's people
that are mad at Trump on the right
because he did the coronavirus stimulus
coronavirus stimulus wasn't big enough
I mean okay if they don't want to vote
Trump in November because of it and
they're gonna help Biden win by one vote
each I'll take it
but the reason they disagree with Trump
might be completely not in line with our
values
so everybody's an ally who helps remove
Trump but the idea that we want to start
shaming never Biden people by saying
these rhinos or even better allies for
us I don't think it's a good idea I
don't think it's pragmatic I don't think
it's based in the facts either hey David
whatever happened to Donald Trump's wall
and does it matter for 2020 so all you
need to know is that Trump is claiming
he did it
Trump is claiming he did it now you
might remember when he was running
Trump's promise was by the end of my
first term we'll have a wall across the
entire US max
go border um that was never going to
happen Trump also said Mexico would pay
for it that was never going to happen
and none of it has happened Trump has
been able to finagle getting about looks
like a hundred and fifty 160 miles of
wall starting to be built some of which
will be completed by November but what
you need to understand is despite that
obviously being a failure by Donald
Trump to do what he promised to do he's
going to claim victory and a lot of his
followers are going to fall for it so
first of all there will be very little
fact-checking of Trump about you
promised the wall across the entire
border what the hell happened
if it happens Trump will say listen
Democrats got in the way coronavirus got
in the way and I built what I was able
to do if it weren't for Democrats I
would have built the whole thing but
we've had a huge success we have a
hundred and fifty miles bill or whatever
and I did everything I could and it is a
victory we have more miles now than we
ever had before you all get it right so
he's going to claim victory no matter
what and that is all that matters optics
is all that matters
it is this bizarre sort of like
Rorschach test of a wedge issue I had
people calling me on live calls a year
and a half ago two years ago there's
this crazy a Republican caller Doug who
sometimes calls and he's from Southern
California and he was saying the wall
the wall the wall the wall and I said
well if Trump doesn't build the wall
during his first term will you still
vote for him for reelection
and he basically said probably which
means that it doesn't really matter if
he builds the wall even just claiming to
have succeeded despite the oppression of
Democrats on the wall most trumpets are
going to vote for him anyway because
they see Biden as worse it's an
incoherent explanation that coronavirus
and Democrats prevented him from from
building it Republicans have also gotten
the way of giving him the funding that
he wants we've talked about all of that
but the 2020 election is going to be
primarily a referendum on the state of
the economy at the time and what that
means about Trump's management of the
country of course it'll be affected by
Corona
but Trump's actual handling of the virus
itself is mostly baked in already it
will be a matter of do we have a sort of
AB between the waves that helps Trump in
November or not I don't believe that the
wall is going to be a factor in anyway
people who are against the wall are
probably already not voting for Trump
people who are who voted for Trump in
2016 and hear him say we did it I made a
hundred and fifty miles and will do more
my second turn they're gonna fall for it
I do not believe it's going to make a
difference if you disagree with me I of
course want to hear from you hey David
whatever happened to the blue lives
matter movement it's interesting because
in the context of the reopen the country
protests all of a sudden all of these
right-wingers who were from the blue
lives matter movement are putting cops
lives at risk attacking them criticizing
them and saying that they are the forces
of government tyranny are they just
hypocrites or what's going on yeah up
beautifully pointed out so when the
black lives matter movement got going an
alternative movement or an alternative
hashtag got going called blue lives
matter meaning okay
black lives matter meaning the lives of
black people killed by police but blue
lives matter our police lives matter and
we need to understand this is their
perspective that a lot of these black
people were killed by police because
police were in danger and that's why
blue lives matter so it's a right-wing
movement that wants to minimize the
issue of police violence against black
Americans and do it by propping up law
enforcement now you've seen a reversal
now that you've seen governor's in many
states say we've got to stay home
businesses should close etc now that
you've seen police enforcing hey this
park is closed you're trespassing you've
got to go you've seen police enforcing
different elements of these stay at home
and distancing guidelines you have seen
those who say respect authority from the
right say oh well now you've got a
disrespect Authority you are seeing
those who say respect the police the
police are the ones that are that are
here telling us how we should
behave let's behave in a way that
doesn't get them angry with us they are
now antagonizing and harassing and
intimidating police who are guarding
state houses for example they're just
hypocrites that that's all it is
listen this is debt and deficit is a
political football they don't really
care about debt and deficit on the right
they just use it when they can to
justify removing a Democrat and voting
for a Republican or when they want to
prop up a Republican they say look
they've cut the deficit even if it's not
true like we're seeing under Donald
Trump it's just a political football
small government small government is for
many people there are principled
libertarians sure but for a lot of these
right-wingers small government is a
political football it is something to
say but then all of a sudden they want
bailouts for this industry and bailouts
for these people and but you know buy
food from farmers and redistribute it to
people and stuff that is completely
antithetical to their worldview they'll
always come up with some way to
rationalize it away but they immediately
abandon their principles as soon as the
situation on the ground changes and it's
much the same here guys
there's no unique respect of law
enforcement or authority from those who
say it's all about law and order it's
all about law and order when they want
to justify the targeting of minority
neighborhoods by law enforcement right
hey look we're law and order you go
where the crime is but all of a sudden
when it's hey wait a second we got it we
got to reopen it I you can see my roots
I need my hair done I need to go buy a
fertilizer as Wonga manure as one guy
said oh whatever now the police are the
enemies they are actually the
perpetuators of tyranny and who knew
when all of these gun people were saying
we need to be protected from government
tyranny who knew that that meant staying
at home and watching Netflix that's the
tyranny that apparently many of them
were imagining so they are hypocrites
but it's not unique is my message
they're hypocrites on a lot of these
issues a lot of these they stake out of
policy positions and values that sound
good in the absence
of reality and as soon as reality hits
sometimes for the right reasons
sometimes for the wrong reasons they
abandon those principles and go to what
is it that I want right now because I'm
essentially a petulant child like the
president astutely asked glad you
brought it up we've got a tremendous
bonus show today get instant access to
the bonus show two ways become a member
at join pakman.com or become a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show I'll
speak to you then otherwise Monday we'll
be back with new program
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]